the CDC is warning Americans about a
possible summer Resurgence of empox
formerly known as monkey pox since last
Summer's outbreak more than 30 000
people in the United States have
contracted the disease Roxanna shabiri
shows us the new concern
we don't really know if people are
developing breakthrough cases because
immunity is waning Dr Karen Krueger says
some patients recently treated at
Chicago's Northwestern Memorial Hospital
had also received both doses at the
genius vaccine but at least we haven't
seen any of those cases that are on the
real you know very severe end of the
spectrum where hospitalization is
required because most of those people
had double vaccinations that is my hope
with pride celebrations starting next
month the CDC is now warning of an mpox
Resurgence and is calling on men who
have sex with men and other people at
high risk to get vaccinated the agency
estimates that only around a quarter of
them have been fully vaccinated three
Studies released last week found that
the two-dose vaccine is 66 to 88 percent
effective at preventing an empox
infection with one dose that figure
drops to 36 to 75 percent Mbox is spread
primarily by skin to skin in contact
common symptoms are rashes scabs and
flu-like symptoms it's rarely fatal
Michael Kelly co-owner of equal Pride
magazine was diagnosed with empox last
summer so loneliness was actually a
symptom mental health isolation is a
huge symptom but he says his symptoms
could have been a lot worse if he hadn't
received his
dose 8 is earlier I'm concerned about
people who don't take this seriously and
don't get vaccinated to protect
themselves and as importantly others for
CBS mornings Roxanna saberi New York